Стівен Гокінг показав світові
необмежені можливості розуму.
Незважаючи на понівечене хворобою тіло, він став
одним із найвідоміших науковців сучасності.
З інвалідного візка та за допомогою пристрою,
що генерує слова, британський фізик
надихав людей по цІлому світу.
Гокінг ставився до свого важкого фізичного стану
з мужністю і дотепністю.
Якби довелося обирати, яким супергероєм бути,
я би обрав Супермена.Він - все те,
чого немає в мене.
Стівен Гокінг народився в англійському Оксфорді
8 січня 1942 року.
Був найстаршим із чотирьох дітей. У 17 років
він здобув стипендію Оксфордського університету.
Стівен вивчав фізику та хімію. Любив наукову
фантастику. Але у 21 рік доля завдала йому
жорсткого удару.
Лікар, який діагностував у мене
боковий аміотрофічний склероз, сказав, що це
вб’є мене через два-три роки. Все життя я жив
із загрозою передчасної смерті.
Гокінг зосередився на темах, які він знав найкраще.
Він почав працювати в галузі теоретичної фізики.
У Кембріджському університеті Стівен досліджував
сфери, які поєднували науку, філософію та релігію,
такі як походження Всесвіту.
Він особливо цікавився чорними дірами і вивчав
це таємниче явище протягом багатьох рокІв.
Він дослідив, що трапляється з матерією,
втягнутою в ці діри. Гокінг розробив численні теорії,
але без остаточних відповідей.
Одне з його найбільших відкриттів полягає в тому,
що чорні діри можуть зникати.
Ця теорія перевернула науковий світ із ніг на голову.
У 1988 році він випустив книгу
"Коротка історія часу". Вона стала бестселером
із мільйонами копій і перекладена на десятки мов.
Стівен Гокінг став відомим громадським діячем.
Він використовував свою популярність,
щоб попередити про небезпеку ядерної війни
та зміну клімату. На публічних дебатах шукав
відповіді й на інші актуальні питання сучасності.
Гокінг також брав активну участь у мирному процесі
між Ізраїлем та Палестиною. Він назвав вторгнення
США до Іраку в 2003 році військовим злочином.
Його стосунки з першою дружиною навіть
надихнули на створення голлівудського фільму.
Гокінг має багато нагород і відзнак
за його дослідження і зусилля, спрямовані
на популяризацію науки серед широкої аудиторії.
У 2007 році він втілив свою мрію, побувавши
у стані невагомості. Вперше за 37 років він міг
рухатися, не перебуваючи в інвалідному візку.
Це було дивовижно!
Я міг би продовжувати ще і ще.
Всесвіте, я вже йду!